sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager on solana luno if
you're just getting into bitcoin it's
the perfect place to start
hey guys anna welcome back to the lehigh
offense show so as always it is powered
by the vc firm icon plus capital and it
is sponsored by blockfi who offer really
exciting interest rates so i've left a
link for you in the comments and in the
description so check that out so joining
me today we have morgan harper former
consumer protection attorney at the
consumer financial protection bureau and
current candidate for u.s senate in ohio
let's bring her in morgan great to meet
you how are you good how are you thanks
for having me
yeah thank you so much for coming on um
it's always so exciting to um you know
speak to people who are involved in
politics that are um talking about
bitcoin so before we get into all of
this um for those that don't know you
could you please give us some background
about you um you know where you're from
and where you grew up yeah for sure so i
am originally from columbus ohio which
is where i am now i was born at the ohio
state university hospital probably
meaningless to you but very important if
anyone is listening who's in ohio and uh
and was given up for adoption and i
lived in a foster home when i was a baby
and then was adopted and raised by my
mom who worked in the public school
system and you know like a lot of folks
went through a lot and i just had some
early life experiences that showed me
the importance of having even one parent
with a stable job and you know the level
of financial vulnerability that we all
could be subject to overnight and that
put me on this track to figure out
what's going on what is this and it led
me to public policy and eventually
politics
so that's such an interesting
background and upbringing i have to just
ask you about that so how important you
know you said it's so important to have
that one stable
parent um you know so how were you able
with such a i guess difficult start able
to you know lift yourself up and be you
know the candidate for ohio
well my mom is pretty incredible she's
78 now and still lives on the east side
of columbus and um and you know she had
when i say a stable job and she worked
in the public school system when she had
to take time off to be able to run and
get us somewhere or go to a doctor's
appointment or a legal appointment when
things were really going down for us and
my parents were going through this crazy
divorce she knew that she would be okay
that she would still have that job that
she had some time off and you know she
wasn't in a union and that that mattered
uh and you know i think what we're
seeing
so much now is there's not a lot of
breathing room for folks but that was
absolutely the story of what allowed us
to get through and then you know and
also i would point to a strong community
which consists of people who have the
ability and bandwidth to look out for
others not just focus on themselves you
know when we couldn't make daycare
payments that we got an extra couple
weeks when we had to figure out how to
get into you know a different housing
situation that we had a neighbor that
allowed us to move in for a few months
so that's that's the foundation of what
put me in a position to be able to get
scholarships to go to first you know a
fancy private school here in central
ohio and then eventually to places like
princeton university stanford law school
it's it doesn't just happen and you know
of course a lot of individual effort but
lots of different people around me that
put me in the position to make that
happen
that's such an interesting story um but
you mentioned multiple times that you
plan to only run for two terms so why
are you so passionate about that
i'm really passionate about that because
i've been in the belly of the beast i've
been in washington dc so you know i
first worked after college at the
federal trade commission which is a
federal agency that regulates consumer
protection competition policy and uh and
i was i was really turned off from that
experience i just didn't feel like folks
were really moving with urgency solve
problems which is the whole reason why i
want to be in government because if
you're not trying to solve problems it's
like what are you doing you could just
be you know in other sectors trying to
make money whatever
and um and it wasn't until you know i
got to the consumer financial protection
bureau and really saw that government
can do things cans can solve problems
for people can really be efficient data
driven all of that that i really started
to believe again and what government
could be um and you know and that that
was a really important milestone for me
to be able to just realize the power the
power of being in public policy
you've spoken previously about i'm sorry
i just actually get to answer your
question sorry about so anyway so once i
was there though i saw
that we could be doing even more in
public policy if we actually had
politicians that were on the side of
getting things done and yeah you know
for me i was able to see in congress
just how much the limitations were
people who weren't that focused on
solving problems who had been corrupted
by money and taking you know direct
donations for people bribes some might
say and instead of actually moving with
that urgency that i was so focused on
that i found in my colleagues at bfpb
we're kind of slowing things down and
you know a lot of times i think people
look for well what was the vote what was
the vote that showed that they were
corrupt or had sold sold us out or
whatever but in washington a lot of
things happen before you even get to the
point of having a vote and in fact the
goal of a lot of the money in politics
is to make sure that things don't go up
for a vote so there is no accountability
and it's all the backroom conversations
and meeting with lobbyists that slows
the process down and prevents anything
from changing and so you know and seeing
that up close that's why one i've made a
commitment to not take corporate money
but then also in order to restore trust
in our institutions to ensure that you
know stay focused on serving people i
also am very committed to only serving
two terms
absolute necessity in my view to be able
to get our institutions back on track
you said that a lot of the money um is
to make sure that nothing is actually
done and not much actually does get
through why do you think that's the case
why do i think people don't want
anything to get done or why does it take
money to do that
why do you think that
they don't want to get things done
well because what we have right now and
i do think we're living through uh
what's a bit of the the end end of time
so to speak of having 40 years of really
opening up the floodgates for money to
enter politics that has enabled our our
institutions like u.s congress to be
captured and then allows the folks that
can fund that capture which are ultra
ultra wealthy and very very very large
corporations to then secure their
dominance of our economy and make it
difficult for small medium-sized
businesses to compete for workers to
really have an advantage when
negotiating for wages all of this and so
it's a it's a pretty clear plan to you
know so
distrust in in the political process
that then lays the groundwork for
economic gains for a very small slice of
the population
speaking of um
transparency and understanding um you
know
more about these political donations you
talked previously about issues to do
with campaign finance and the ability
for corporations to essentially donate
directly to politicians so how would we
then fix that
and where for you does blockchain
technology come in
well how we fix it is i mean there are a
couple of options and you know ideally
we would have legislation campaign
finance reform certainly that has been
introduced in in congress now to do that
and it would be great if we had
functioning institutions that could pass
things that would restore
credibility to a lot of our institutions
but it's it's not happening and i i have
to be honest i'm not i'm not that
optimistic about legislation that would
change campaign finance laws uh getting
through right now just based on what the
dynamics are politically in congress and
i do
you know i wish that we didn't have
barriers things like the filibuster here
in our system that prevent that from
happening but that's just what it is and
so in the meantime i think it's really
essential that we have individuals
candidates and then eventually folks who
become elected officials like we started
to see in the last few years who are
making this commitment on their own we
don't need to wait for laws to pass to
know what the right thing is to do and
we could just have people who decide to
do the right thing and then that changes
the whole
political calculus of what the public
finds acceptable and i think that
unfortunately is is our best route right
now and the most efficient route and you
see it changing i mean when i first ran
for office a couple of years ago and i
said you know i'm not taking corporate
pac money i mean people knew what it was
or what it means to be sold out to large
corporations and all of that but there
wasn't a really great understanding of
pacs and the fact that we have
politicians who are just directly taking
money from the people that we're
supposed to be regulating and passing
legislation to apply to and you know one
one question that really stuck with me
and and really informed just how i've
spent the last couple of years and open
and being open to what it's going to
take to fix this is you know someone
said it at some point
well morgan you know you're critiquing
all this corporate money in politics but
you know you also have people who donate
to your campaign who live out of state
what's the difference
and i was i was a bit shocked you know i
always try to lead with empathy and
understanding for everybody's coming up
this stuff from a different place but
wow because if if we have people who
don't understand what the difference is
between an individual who's giving me of
their you know full voting money to my
campaign and
a t for example who is giving ten
thousand dollars to a sitting elected
official then we as a public have a
misunderstanding of power and how it
works in this country how it is wielded
through our government and how it is
tried to use is used against us to
prevent most of us from being more
financially stable and that is a big
problem and so by having individual
people candidates and then eventually
elected officials as well who are
educating the public by making this
commitment
that can have a big impact then about
what criteria folks use to then vote and
choose elected officials and i've seen
that even over a couple of years just
focused on ohio there's a much better
understanding of the influence of money
and politics and the desire to do
something to stop it
yeah i definitely think um the public
this is sort of a global thing
desires more transparency right now and
i think people definitely feel that
they've been lied to um but you made
this really long thread a couple of
months ago which is actually how um i
came across you because i'm british so
i'm not directly involved in american
politics um but the thread was about
bitcoin and the importance of
decentralization so can you explain to
me your view on bitcoin and i guess
really just you know what drew you to it
so i first started hearing about
bitcoin crypto blockchain technology
when i was at the consumer financial
protection bureau and you know i started
at the the bureau in 2013 and so it was
now time flies we were talking about
that uh gray hairs are coming that was
almost ten years ago and uh you know and
it was it wasn't part of my core
portfolio but they were just people who
were meeting with folks that were in the
industry excited about the technology
and coming back and you know sharing
stories about that so sort of passively
started to hear about it then and you
know it's been interesting over the last
year just having more people i was
having more people in ohio who were
talking to me about how they were
excited about it how they were you know
investing how they were thinking about
applications of blockchain and then also
you know creatives looking at nfts and
what that could all mean as well uh and
so you know it seemed like wow okay this
has gotten to a much broader uh set of
folks this isn't just some niche thing
as much anymore and i need to be paying
closer attention to it as well as
someone who seeks to represent people in
this state uh and so you know started
just reading more about it talking to
more people about it and wanted to put
out a statement that just says hey look
i mean i am all about trying to
decentralize power and control and
promote economic freedom among as many
people as possible and like we were just
talking about i mean i think that is
what a lot of the corruption has limited
our ability to be more economically free
and so if this sector has the ability to
broaden opportunity this is something
that we need to be talking about paying
attention to learning listening uh and
and it's been cool i mean since we
posted that i've engaged with so many
more people um in this area hearing
stories people reached out to me
in ohio who had never heard about the
campaign or anything that i stood for
that were messaging me on facebook like
oh so cool to see someone who's running
for office who's talking about this um
and that was great that was great
because you know we we've been living
through this era where i think there's a
lot of you know division polarization no
you you're on this side i'm on that side
and i want to i want to try to bring in
as many people as possible and and be
open to different perspectives that
folks have
yeah i mean speaking of um the division
and the polarization a lot of people in
the community in the crypto community in
bitcoin in particular would say that
bitcoin is apolitical um whereas ted
cruz um a couple of weeks ago i think it
was at cpac in florida made this really
loud statement saying that the left
don't like bitcoin because they can't
control it um
and
there's there's truth and there's also
not truth to that you know it's quite
it's quite a broad statement um so
you know where where do you stand on
that you're obviously a democrat and
you're interested in bitcoin so what do
you think about you know the left at the
quote unquote not being able to control
that yeah i mean first of all let's be
clear
ted cruz and and this isn't and this is
really important and this is something
that i have come to after having a lot
of conversations with people in this
space over you know the last few months
is
we we cannot just focus on one thing
that people talk about first of all i
don't know what it means to speak for
the left okay i don't know i don't know
what that means i don't know who you're
talking about but i do know that ted
cruz is often not talking about anything
that's about advancing
most people in this country doing better
than the day before okay and and that's
not a party thing and and that's what we
really need to be focused on is like
we're we're moving into this era and i
do think that this is something you know
when you say that a lot of folks that
are into bitcoin identify as apolitical
well i do think there's something to
that where we're in we're moving into
this era where people are sick of the
politics they're sick of parties they're
very skeptical of status quo and
leadership and rightly so in many cases
but folks like ted cruz are not
advancing us to a higher place
in my view and that isn't my view as a
democrat that's my view as morgan harper
who lives in this country and is
watching what's going on and
i don't hear any ideas so just because
and this is the real danger and i have
talked to people in the community who
identify as single-issue voters well
more power to you i mean there's a lot
of
there's a lot of privilege built into
being a single-issue voter i would say
right now but even if that even if
that's where you're coming from i mean
look at what some of the other things
that these folks are saying people like
ted cruz people like you know josh
mandel who's running in the republican
primary on this side it's it can't be
enough that they just put the avatar up
on their twitter right it's like what
else are these people standing for and
trust and believe it is not about
expanding freedom
okay so we need to be a little bit more
nuanced and
analytical about what who we're
supporting and why and what else they
stand for i would say uh that would be
one of my my charges to the community is
got to be more responsible than that
yeah i think you know i i'm
also personally really skeptical um
about politicians that you know come out
saying that they they support bitcoin
and then you look at their track record
and it sort of just isn't aligned with
you know
freedom and and all sorts of things you
know they could say they like bitcoin
and then two minutes later they banned
bitcoin mining you know so it's it is it
is weird and we do have women being able
to do what they want with their bodies
for example right it's like i don't know
i mean i don't want to get too political
but this is the reality that we're
living in here it's like these are
people that want to try to tell kids
what they can learn okay they want to
also prevent us from being able to
manage our own reproductive rights
decisions and just because they like
bitcoin then we're gonna ignore all that
other stuff that doesn't sit well with
me at all
i understand i think it's worth you know
looking at the the individual's entire
voting history and you know checking if
it is congruent with what they're what
they're supporting um but i think you
know right now america is at this kind
of um crossroads you know like is is
america gonna be at the forefront of
this revolution or um like it should be
um or is it going to be left behind and
you know people were very concerned over
um
the
biden's executive order so i'd love to
hear your take on it
concerned about
a concern before it came out or after
i think both well i can speak about the
after bit that's more to do with cbdc's
which we we can discuss um but they were
more concerned about essentially just
stifling innovation and you know we can
talk about elizabeth warren and her
approach afterwards but i'd like to know
whether you think you know his executive
order is positive and where america is
going to be
moving forward is it going to be left
behind yeah well i i actually saw it as
a positive thing because to me what it
was is one acknowledging that the space
has grown and there's a lot of interest
in it and that there needs to be
some attention paid by the federal
government to be able to explore what
regulation could look like what
innovation should look like and how to
best foster innovation and also balance
you know and mitigate any risk uh
that to me is a validation of just the
growth of the space and and then you
know the worst case scenario to me is
folks just ignoring it all together and
then continuing to dash it without
necessarily having full information so
i don't i took it i took it as a
positive and then you know looking
through the order what the charge is is
to different agencies so the whole of
government approach having different
agencies collect data get information
that'll probably lead i imagine to you
know further hearings that will happen
on the hill that there could be meetings
that happen that are organized directly
by the executive branch by the white
house and in further educating people
about you know what the opportunities
are so i took it i took it as a positive
yeah you're obviously you know part of
this next generation of politicians but
i just from what i can see the current
administration
don't get it you know there was that
shocking video that came out of
elizabeth warren essentially refusing to
listen to somebody explaining why
bitcoin isn't the best when it comes to
um you know illicit activity so you know
my question to you is you know why don't
they understand it and do you think that
perhaps they are choosing
to ignore it
i mean it's hard for me to speak for
others and you know where they're where
they're coming from and and why they're
saying certain things but you know i i
have found and this sometimes can happen
in in washington that there sometimes
can be a very a reflexive reaction and
then once there's been a generally held
view then other people just start
sharing that generally held view and i
do think it's important or i feel a
responsibility as someone who is seeking
to lead to
engage collect more information you know
like i was saying before be open-minded
and then form for my own my own opinions
and and i think in in especially when
you're looking at you know regulation
and what that might look like and that
that was what i learned being at the
consumer financial protection bureau is
you engage with all sorts of folks from
industry you engage with people from
advocacy community and you come up with
what's the best policy and i i have a
similar approach here i think you know
one thing i would point to though where
there probably is the source of some
skepticism by a lot of people you know
coming from the consumer protection
space is
there's there's this sense that you know
with the fintech and with a lot of the
the financial technology companies that
emerged and this was really growing you
know when i was at cfpb and certainly
has continued to grow after uh that
folks were sold kind of a
fake bill of goods so to speak right you
know that there's going to be this
revolution that's coming and it's really
going to help and change be a game
changer for the unbanked and be much
more equitable than the traditional
banking system and it doesn't seem like
that has really proven to be true i mean
we see a lot of replication of some of
the dynamics that people could label i
believe rightly as predatory dynamics
that happen in the traditional banking
system that also happen when you have
fintech companies that are just layering
on top of the existing system and so i
think that it is incumbent on people who
you know really believe in in bitcoin
and crypto in blockchain technology in
the possibilities to even when it gets
frustrating
continue to to educate people and engage
and you can't just shut down and i think
that you know the same responsibility
for folks who are in elected office uh
we we also or seek to be there you know
we we can't shut down either we need to
be able to continue to learn and come up
with what's the best approach to protect
the innovation and have the usb a leader
on it and then also mitigate the risks
so how do we bridge the gap between
those who are currently setting
legislation on on all of this
who
sort of refuse to have an open mind
about it um so how do we how do we
bridge that gap of education and sort of
you know explaining it in a balanced way
that you know
we understand you know regulation might
be necessary um but let's like
understand correctly what we're what
we're regulating essentially like how do
you bridge that educational gap
well you know i think having platforms
like this that are continuing to be a
source of information for people that
are a little bit outside of the
traditional media is really helpful uh
and because
well i've seen and it's been interesting
i mean even over the last couple of
months and you know you're getting at
this when you're mentioning ted cruz
that there's this view oh the left is
anti antiolive right right and i
actually you know found just through
engaging a little bit and then having a
couple of examples of people who are
willing to talk about it that that
narrative has changed now and that's
that's broken down a little bit because
you see examples of people who are on
the more progressive side of things who
are democrats again who knows what we're
talking about when we say the left um
but you know who are willing to are
willing to talk about it and so that
that changes you know the whole
landscape and so that's important to
have platforms like this but then also
you know when you look specifically at
institutions of government uh that there
there are different branches and they're
different branches for a reason so yeah
okay you know hitting some frustrating
moments with particular people in
congress well there's this whole white
house that you know has also moved
forward with this executive order and
being able to apply more resources there
and then they also will have a separate
platform for how to continue to engage
the public and that leads to things like
i've seen even now in more you know
mainstream media publications that
starting to cover it in a more balanced
way and what does balance mean balance
to me and this should be the goal of all
journalism in my view though it's not
always the case is presenting
information and letting readers decide
for themselves not so much
editorializing and i have seen you know
especially over the last month just more
more coverage that seems to me to have a
much different tone much more of an
educational tone and less of a no no no
no like here's why you shouldn't even be
paying attention to this
yeah i think um
the community feel
not to speak on behalf of the community
but i know that we have seen a lot of um
media which is just so incorrect you
know whether it be about like uh
bitcoin's energy consumption um you know
there's a total disregard for actually
how the renewable energy could actually
be better for the environment um you
know there's a total
disregard for a lot of facts so i know
that that would be appreciated if
we started to see you know a lot more um
of a factual and honest conversation um
so
so do you think we could get america
would get to a point whereby
you know there is too much regulation um
and
innovation begins to
move elsewhere
it's certainly possible it's certainly
possible i mean well you know i couldn't
say that now we're in a place where
there's too much regulation but now
we're at a place where it's just unknown
where we're going from here and like i
said i mean to me the executive order
was a step in the right direction of
gathering more information before moving
too quickly in one direction or the
other that's good that's a good starting
place
yeah always always the possibility that
you know there's a lot of regulation in
an industry that isn't necessarily then
allowing the industry to grow but it
doesn't appear that that's where we're
at right now and i think by continuing
to educate engage and in this the other
thing i would point to is because this
is a question i get a lot is you know
what are the specific use cases it seems
like
and sometimes i'll i'll be real with you
i mean sometimes people struggle to come
up with those of what are the use cases
that make this you know so much better
than what's come before in traditional
banking and look you know i i am very
open about critiquing a lot of things in
the traditional financial system but
then you know being able to point to
these are the specific ways in which
this is an improvement and not a
replication of you know what already is
not working in the traditional space and
like i said i mean i think that is
that's what breeds some of the
skepticism because people feel like that
is what happened with a lot of the
promises of fintech for example
how do you speak to people in ohio about
it when they ask you about it
so usually it's uh people so most often
it's people asking me why am i talking
about it at all
and and you know like we like we just
discussed i mean i i tell people it's
like hey look we have a lot of people in
our state that are pretty interested in
this and different communities different
sectors um i sometimes i find that
people are surprised to learn that you
know folks are interested in the
creative sectors and how that might
allow people to be able to capture more
of the ownership and financial benefits
of what you know the work that they're
doing so there's a lot of there's a lack
of understanding but usually now because
i've been speaking out about it more i'm
getting a lot of questions on why are
you talking about this at all uh and and
that's interesting because you know i
got more of those i would say a couple
of months ago but now as there's more
media coverage of the topic generally
people are like oh interesting you were
already kind of talking about this and
now it's moving forward and the
environmental thing is a big big issue
and so you know i don't want to at all
minimize that i mean that is something
that when folks are asking me about it
they bring up very specifically about
you know how isn't this an environmental
disaster and how are we going to be able
to possibly you know avoid don't we
already have so many issues with the
climate um but you know being able to
tell people hey you know that's one of
the questions i have to the community
and
i i'm always looking for more
information about like okay if we're
going to be moving forward with this how
do we mitigate you know bad
environmental outcomes that has to be a
priority as we're looking at you know
colossal damage coming from the climate
crisis
what's your answer for that
yeah i think it's a fair question my
answer is energy arbitrage so the fact
so for the very first time and i feel so
i it's so hard to explain this but i'm
going to give it a go so for the very
first time we're actually seeing the
decentralization of energy so you don't
have to um you know burn fossil fuels or
do whatever you do to
you know get that energy in certain
parts of the world you can use renewable
energy from anywhere
so you know whether it's um whether it's
solar energy geothermal energy um you
know hydroelectric you can go to places
where there's unused energy a lot of the
times people build um you know like
these these huge power plants and
they're often built for the
energy usage of tomorrow meeting in 20
years time so now you have all of that
infrastructure that's built and it's
just wasted whereas miners because it's
decentralized can mine from anywhere in
the world so an amazing example is in el
salvador so they're literally using the
geothermal energy from volcanoes with
zero co2 emissions to mine and to secure
the network so it's energy arbitrage so
it can be done anywhere so and then also
because the energy is cheaper because
either it's renewable or it's wasted and
much of the time it's wasted um
miners are actually incentivized to seek
out that energy does that make sense
because
because it is so expensive to secure the
network they are literally incentivized
to secure out greener energy because
it's going to be cheaper um
and never before are you seeing you know
the decentralization of that energy so
energy arbitrage i think it's great
yeah yeah yeah and that that is what
i've heard from other people too and um
yeah and we just have to continue to
show examples of it i think for folks to
really get that and and
and mitigate you know what is a really
big fear is people are really concerned
about the climate crisis rightly and
knowing how this isn't going to be
perpetuating the same dynamics i think
is really important
yeah absolutely i just i i wish that we
could have that nuanced conversation um
because people always talk about it you
know it's the end of the world but but
it's not you know it's literally better
for the environment because you know
with the traditional banking system and
with gold and the the entire um you know
in the gold industry you literally can't
do that there's no energy arbitrage um
so
you know for me it's just quite obvious
and i just hope that you know we can
have these honest conversations um but
we'll get there we'll get there um but
there was a part of the executive order
which spoke about cbdc's central bank
digital currencies and i don't know you
know if you're involved in that much but
i just you know wanted to get your
opinion on central bank digital
currencies because for me personally i
think they're quite dangerous
yeah i i haven't delved as much into
that so i would probably be more in
question mode there
yeah what dangerous why
so central bank digital currencies would
basically be like a cryptocurrency um
that is controlled by the government so
it would be
on a block on blockchain technology but
the money is programmable that's what
concerns me personally um so you know i
have these concerns that if
there is this climate crisis and things
are getting worse
we could all be using the cbdc and you
know you go fill up your car and it's
refused
just because you've reached your
pollution limit because you know we're
in this energy crisis and now
that money that you have that that is
yours isn't really yours so it can be
programmed to do certain things and even
you know even there's a lot of um
we're living in this time of
disinformation and misinformation and
what was misinformation last week is now
fact this week um you know so so facts
are changing um so there's also concern
you know that if you if you retweeted a
certain person on twitter and you liked
a certain post or you went to a certain
protest you know your money could be
frozen and we saw that happen in canada
so with cbdc's essentially it's just
more efficient for the government to
have that control of your money hmm
yeah yeah no and i mean this is
definitely something i've heard from a
lot of people you know in the community
is concerned about you know a lot of
government control and and not having
transparency over you know how some
um regulations could change
i think that's fair and um and you know
but the counter to that is often okay
but then we can't have people that are
just operating totally outside of the
system and there's no transparency and
that's where i think there is a lack of
understanding is you know they're in in
its best form my
my understanding is that you would have
a lot of transparent you have a lot of
transparency on what's happening in the
ledger and who's doing what and um and
so that's less of a concern but yeah i
hear it i hear what you're saying
haven't gone deeply into that but yeah
understood
yeah so with with the ledger i think i
love the idea of transparency but my
concern and also be good to get your
opinion on this um would be that it
would be one way so a lot of people feel
like you know they're giving all these
these dollars in taxes and all this
stuff and they're not really seeing
where that's where that money's going
you know whether it's going to fund wars
whether it's going you know to different
big corporations um so
with a cbdc
it would be sort of a one-way
relationship um you know so government
would see would see every single
transaction that the population have
done but we wouldn't see where that
money goes so
do you think and i tweeted this
yesterday we could ever live in a
society or in a world whereby you know
taxes are transparent on a ledger so we
can see from start to finish exactly
where those dollars are going
i think that would be really cool
and it should be some expectation of
what government is i mean on the the
federal level is probably a challenging
place to start with that but definitely
you know at the more local level for
example i
i i actually don't see why that couldn't
that couldn't happen now
free of uh even having a ledger right is
being able to demand transparency from
our government on where money is going
and then what we got from that
expenditure
seems very basic right and when we get
out you know what we were talking about
earlier the lack of trust in our
institutions i do think it's because
people have no idea what's going on i
mean for example i grew up around people
yeah i got this scholarship to go nice
private school a lot of people were
pretty conservative and there was this
view it's like federal government every
dollar waste of money that's why i don't
want higher taxes that's why i want to
be able to give to charity rather than
having my money go to social services
all of that and i do think that you know
some of that is those are people that
just philosophically do not believe in
government at all
okay
i'm not one of those people uh i think
it has a lot to do with for many people
about just not trusting and having
transparency around what we're doing
with this money and so yeah i mean i i
am all about transparency i am all about
accountability those are two of the
guiding principles of my entire life
and uh and certainly what i think we
need more of in government and um but
yeah but i guess you know
and
not to not to turn a lot of questions
back on you but i am kind of curious
about yeah because what like what would
be your response though to couldn't that
transparency happen even free of
a ledger for example like couldn't you
just have for example you know the
president a mayor that's just going to
say
here's the money we spent
here's what it went towards here's what
didn't work out about that that money
and we're gonna change you know moving
forward next year for this reason
something like that
but that would require putting your
trust in that centralized body right
whether it's the mayor whether it's the
government um and i think we've just
been proven time and time again that we
just can't do that and i think the whole
narrative surrounding crypto and
decentralization and particularly
bitcoin actually is so that you don't
have to trust a third party to you know
potentially um
you know doctor those documents you know
make them false change something um and
so i think the only way to truly
understand where that tax money is going
and how it's being spent is to have that
decentralized ledger um where we can see
exactly what's happened but i just i
can't imagine i can't imagine a world
where that would ever be the case i
think if
they sort of say you know it's a
national security issue we're not
allowed to know yeah
that's why that's what you know well
it's really cool to talk to you about
this uh
that's why i actually think starting
with a local government
might be more interesting there because
yes yeah you take away the life or death
stakes of everything that's going on
it's like okay well now we're talking
about collecting the trash
and
making sure that you know rec centers
are opened on time and this kind of
thing and
you know moderate stakes at best right
okay um and so that seems like a place
to really experiment with these things
and make the case and and i don't know i
found once you start opening people up
to transparency and accountability
nobody wants to go back from that right
and so being able to yeah you know apply
the ledger in that way could be because
i agree with you i mean right now it's a
rare politician that even agrees to not
take any corporate money and agree to
term limits and self-imposing them but
uh so you probably do need some
mechanism to drive that transparency and
accountability that's not dependent on
an individual committing to it but i
would love to believe that we're working
towards a world that we have people in
elected office that just want that
anyway you know for for the good of the
people uh but yeah and not hollyannish
that we have a long way to go there
well you make an interesting point you
know you can do this on a state level
because it's not life and death you know
you don't have the entire you know
establishment you know that you could
that could go wrong um so on a state
level how do you
plan i guess
to start
implementing these ideas
well you know so i'm running for the
federal seat um
and so i haven't you know in terms of on
the campaign or anything i wouldn't say
that we've we've done anything to apply
it directly but you know it is it is
interesting to just be able to have
these conversations with people as we
build towards what i hope is you know a
better future where people really trust
government and so you know it's
interesting to think about for example i
don't know once elect and i'm just
totally brainstorming here with you like
no i love it i love it um but you know
for example as a us senator you get a
budget you get to run your constituent
services office and your
your office in you know in washington
legislative office and having full
transparency around
what that budget's going towards
and applying you know the use of
a ledger or something in that way i
don't know that that could be
interesting and so the public knows
exactly well this is how much i got to
serve you and this is what it went
towards and and this couldn't happen
i love that i love that idea i mean one
thing that you know i've talked about a
lot traveling around the state that's
short of that but getting at the same
theme to me is you know hosting a lot of
town halls and keeping people engaged on
what's going on i get the question of
okay well morgan you know you say your
grassroots you're going to be different
but what does that look like in a
day-to-day way you know as a as a
grassroots no corporate money u.s
senator and i point to things like that
you know the typical model is you get
elected you see a lot of somebody as
they're trying to get elected once
you're elected it's like bye bye see you
in the next six years but i want to
maintain that connectivity and i do
think it would be interesting to to
consider how you apply the technology to
feed into that you know consistent
communication with the electorate and
also transparency around what the
resources that are going to one
individual center senator are are going
towards and you know how they're getting
applied
yeah i think it'd be fascinating and you
know
if you're able to to do that and lead
that um i know i can there'd just be so
much support behind you because people
do they feel entirely disillusioned um
you know even here in the uk it's just
just globally um it is it is global yeah
and and it's i mean it it's
heartbreaking in a lot of ways and you
know i had a conversation with someone
who is in in my network very skeptical
of all of this um and you know we talked
through
um just how many people i i engage with
who are excited about it and
and i think it was a humbling moment for
that person because what it's getting at
is what you're saying it's like people
are distrustful people are disillusioned
if we agree that it's rational that
people find themselves in that place
then we can't just cut off the
mechanisms that folks are finding to be
a gateway to something better it's
incumbent on us to both fix the
institutions
and have better people who are
inhabiting them who are more honest who
invite that transparency and
accountability but then also recognize
you know in the meantime this is
providing value to people and and
there's and there's ways for you know
how the technology develops here to
maybe feed into that larger goal as well
so
more than anything that's where i land
on hey look disillusionment rational in
my view we have been completely misled
by a lot of people who are supposed to
be looking out for us they have been
bought off and are not not looking out
for us there's a lot of awareness about
that some people are capitalizing on
that awareness and trying to further
mislead people and take us down an even
worse route but i individually am
offering myself as somebody who's like
hey agree with you honest about what's
gone wrong but really really committed
to building towards a better future that
is more free for all of us and and i and
when i say all of us i truly mean all of
us and that's something that i think we
need to see not just here in ohio not
just across the united states but to
your point globally globally and we need
to and we need to move forward on these
things as quickly as we can because in a
lot of ways we're running out of time
yeah no i totally agree with you and to
what extent do you think that this is
going to become you know either a
partisan or a bipartisan issue um you
know and it's going to be
one of those one of those one of those
defining issues whether a bit like you
know guns abortion and lgbt rights
things like that
you know i had someone who mentioned to
me uh that they thought it was going
down that route
and
i hope not i hope not yeah
and you know and even on those other
issues that you named that have become
so
polarizing i'm trying to chart out you
know a different a different path here
where it acknowledges
different viewpoints but then also
doesn't allow us to be totally captured
in whatever corner we find ourselves in
because
you know you know what that feeds into
the overall disillusionment and then
we're just yes we're repeating the same
cycle and so you know like take for
example something like guns that
now is presented as this highly partisan
issue it's like well you know the
reality of that is that there are a lot
of people who probably identify as
democrats who also really love owning
guns okay and so the issue is not gun
ownership the issue is that we've had
organizations like the nra through a lot
of money that has infiltrated washington
dc that has made people think that this
is a yes or no issue when in fact the
middle is much grayer and what most
people agree on is that we need to be
doing things to prevent accidents
suicides homicides involving guns and so
similarly here i mean to me the reality
is much more gray than you would
necessarily get especially from you know
when i first started really engaging in
this space and what media would cover is
that i don't know when i'm not when i'm
beyond the political pundit stage
average person is kind of like one i
have no idea what this is at all or two
it's like oh i've heard some things
about that that's interesting or three
hey i know a lot about this i'm really
excited about it and i don't care what
all these people are saying and that
that to me is then again as a leader of
responsibility as a leader is to create
space for all of those folks to engage
learn and then come up with what we want
to we want to see moving forward
yeah and you made an interesting point
earlier as well when you spoke about
that um you know talking about
disillusionment and sort of
but the wrong thing when people see an
alternative to the current system
banning that
is just the worst thing you can do
you know it feeds into it yeah i i yeah
i think that's right and also it it does
another way that it feeds into it is it
seems to disregard what's not working
about the existing system and this is
something you know i pointed to in in
that thread or maybe the one we did
after of you know take for example
something like overdraft fees
overdraft fees are totally
messed up they are predatory there is no
reason why with existing technology that
banks can't know when you have money and
when you don't and if you don't have
money they can just reject the
transaction instead of charging people
who don't have a lot of money thirty
dollars or whatever right and so
yeah and then what once people see is
like oh so suddenly you're gonna be all
know on this thing but that implicitly
makes it seem like everything is
completely fine in what we've got
further loss of credibility and um and
so yeah honesty i think what this moment
that we're living through and it's a
prolonged moment and 2020 as we can call
it is just a real cry for honesty and
more transparency and more
accountability and it'll it's incumbent
on us that you know those of us who
really believe in that
living up to that and then finding each
other as quickly as we can like i said
because
the alternative the alternative is dark
and i do believe that we can have you
know not to get too hokey here but a
brighter future um but it's not a
guarantee but it starts with lasting
no i agree the honesty transparency um
it's the best way forward um so just
finally then off topic is a side topic
because i'm still really fascinated by
um the difficult like i love i love the
kind of story which is a difficult
upbringing and then you know make
something amazing i i really love that
and i value it a lot because i'm i'm big
on personal responsibility and i'm big
on you know
sort of saying it doesn't matter what
happened i can still make something
great so what would be um
i guess some sort of words of wisdom or
you know three tips
just for people who are trying to build
something i know i know it's cliche but
it is nice um people who are trying to
build something yeah yeah people who are
trying to build something and they sort
of feel you know disillusioned with
everything that's going on um and
what can they do right now especially
with inflation skyrocketing and
the way the world is right now yeah yeah
well i i just encourage
people to
to leap i mean you know i i got into
this politics thing and everybody you
know the the political punditry class
here at ohio was kind of like who is she
she's going nowhere all of that but what
what people like that misunderstand is
that
folks that are just regular people are
very aware of what's going on and are
fed up and and then if you give some if
you present to the public something that
is authentic and that they can believe
in i find people rally behind it and so
you know i i had to learn this because
you know one of the other uh outcomes
from my upbringing which you know really
put me in a position to succeed in a
very superficial good degree sort of way
is it can make you a little bit nervous
about slipping behind again right and
never wanting to feel financially
vulnerable and being a little more
risk-averse and you know that
i i don't want anyone to think that we
need to be leaping we need to be
swinging big we need to be confident and
there are a lot of people who when you
take those swings will line up behind
you and uh as long as you're being
authentic in what you're trying to do so
you know i think we have a system right
now and this is one of the policy issues
that i'm really focused on is rewards
you know a select few from feeling that
they're comfortable to take those risks
and not have any you know negative
repercussions from them and i want to
broaden you know broaden economic
opportunity broaden the ability for a
lot of us more of us to be entrepreneurs
and really be free that's the goal and
we can do it
i really like that i really appreciate
that i think um your your passion for
freedom and transparency is totally
aligned um you know with your with your
interest in decentralization and crypto
so i'm really excited to see what you do
i really hope you're able to um you know
make some changes and implement some
positive changes as well um where can
people you know get involved in your
campaign how can people follow you um
what yeah plug yourself yeah yeah for
sure morganharper.org is our website on
all social platforms mh408 so mh number
four oh and reach out let's stay in
touch and really appreciate everybody's
support we're in our final few weeks
here may thirds our primary so it's uh
it's game time for sure
well best of luck thank you so much for
coming on um you know and letting us
know exactly what's happening um and
yeah i'll be following thanks so much
morgan thank you talk to you soon
[Music]